aujourd'hui je reçois une nouvelle
invitée pour la série dans son corps
elle s'appelle margot elle vient
évidemment nous parler de sa
particularité physique mais surtout de
comment apprendre à vivre avec margot
tient la chaîne vivre avec sur youtube
et elle fait aussi des interventions et
des conférences de sensibilisation au
handicap
salut margot est ce que tu peux nous
expliquer quelle est la particularité
physique à toi alors ouais c'est le
syndrome d'ehlers danlos est une maladie
génétique rare qui touche le tissu
conjonctif qui soutient l'ensemble de
nos organes mais margot a déjà expliqué
tout ça dans une de ces vidéos
je vous mets liens dans la description
aller la voir est ce que tu te souviens
du moment où tu t'es rendu compte que tu
avais ce syndrome alors ça a été très
vague parce que j'ai eu trois ans même
plus en fait depuis ma naissance mais
j'ai vraiment eu deux trois ans de
grosses douleurs inexpliquées et le
médecin que je suis allé voir qui m'a
renvoyé vers le service pour un
diagnostic et c'est
deuxième médecin que j'allais voir pour
pour ses douleurs là et ça a été un
processus très lent en fait très bas que
j'ai trouvé des informations sur
internet avant qu'on me confirme que
c'était bien ça et en même temps mon
diagnostic mon premier diagnostic pas si
on avait plusieurs a été un diagnostic à
demi-mot en me disant mais on a pas de
tests génétiques on peut pas être sûr
donc si vous avez des enfants vous
poserai des questions si on vous dit que
vous avez peut-être donc peut-être ce
qui est pas du tout une réponse tiède
donc ça a été très très vague comme au
diagnostic avec l'âge à peu près j'avais
15 ans qu'un savant à peu près et j'ai
eu mes douleurs au collège mais je
pensais au collège que tout le monde
avait ce genre de douleur et pour moi
c'était quelque chose de normal et
l'impact sur ma vie était relativement
faible parce que je pensais que c'était
quelque chose de que tout le monde avait
au lycée par exemple j'étais
déscolarisés plusieurs mois chaque année
est en terminale
j'allais encore peut-être un jour sur 3
donc j'avais la chance d'être en
internat ce qui figurait pas dans chaque
fois de rentrer chez moi tout ça mais
c'était c'était quand même c'est
embêtant et surtout quand c'est à
l'adolescence d'un moment où se
construit un moment le rapport aux
autres est super important c'était
délicat chez les principaux symptômes
sont des douleurs qui peuvent toucher un
peu tout le corps une souplesse extrême
des membres de la fatigue et une peau
très fragile parce que tu peux expliquer
un peu progressivement commenté passer
des douleurs au
l'autre signe a commencé je devais avoir
peut-être sept ou huit ans et en fait
j'ai été suivie dans un centre pour
enfants tous les tous les six mois
j'avais un rendez-vous pour surveiller
mon hyper laxiste et est surveillée de
scoliose qui en fait ça j'avais lu ne
pas être une scoliose mais une
déformation en plus du ahly parle excité
et j'ai fait ça jusqu'à jusqu'au milieu
du collège où tous les six mois j'avais
mon rendez vous et donc des petites j'ai
pris l'habitude de me déshabiller devant
des médecins de ne pas poser de question
de les laisser toucher mon corps de les
laisser critiquer mon corps aussi parce
que à la puberté
j'ai pris du poids comme absolument
toutes les filles à la puberté et a été
critiqué donc voilà déjà et ensuite j'ai
eu des douleurs au dos qu'on m'a dit
diagnostiqué comme caustique et grands
comme mots comme douleur de croissance
j'avais très souvent des entorses en cm2
j'ai pas pu faire une seule séance de
psy j'ai fait une séance de sport
justement une séance de judo de l'année
parce que j'avais des béquilles tout le
temps j'avais des entorses mais en
permanence au collège j'avais de plus en
plus de douleur j'étais très très
fatiguée je rentrais du collège à 6
heures le soir je m'endormais en fait et
je me faisais pour rire comme du poisson
pourri parce que je n'allais pas prendre
ma douche parce que ça c'est normal
quand tu rentres du collège tu fais tes
devoirs qui fut fait à douche
ben non moi je m'endormais je dormais
une heure deux heures tous les soirs et
ensuite au lycée je suivais retient de
l'internât en bretagne avec le pimac
qu'on connaît à la bretagne
j'adore la bretagne je suis à moitié
bretonne j'ai passé trop dans le bas
mais il pleut quand même vachement et
j'étais tout au bout de la bretagne
horrible pour les articulations c'était
pas bien du tout et je pense que c'est
en partie pour ça que j'ai commencé à
voir vraiment très mal et c'est dé
douleur qui m'empêchait la main pour
céder doigt qui me faisait pleurer je
pouvais pas me tenir assise plus d'un
quart d'heure je savais pas ce que
c'était donc avec les médecins de
l'infirmerie on est passé par tous les
stades par le pourquoi tu fais semblant
d'avoir mal par le jeu c'est parce que
tu as far le monde va t'allonger
tu reviens après j'ai été envoyé aux
urgences j'ai été envoyé voir design
littéralement de dizaines de médecins
différents pendant les vacances de la
première à la terminale j'ai en fait mon
diagnostic sida que j'ai fait une seule
année au lycée avec mon diagnostic ce
qui est pas énorme quand t'as pas de
diagnostic à donner aux profs les
améliorations sont plus compliquées à
avoir parce que t'as pas de diagnostic
donc tu pourrais faire semblant et j'ai
été diagnostiqué au lycée enfin et c'est
venu comme un soulagement en fait
beaucoup de personnes pourraient se dire
quand on a une maladie chronique qui en
plus n'a pas de traitement parce que
tout ce que j'essaie du palliatif c'est
pour améliorer les douleurs c'est pour
améliorer les dollars c'est pour rendre
les douleurs plus faible c'est pour
m'aider à plus me déplacer diminue la
fatigue mais c'est pas quelque chose qui
vient traiter le gène en fait puisqu'on
n'a pas encore découvert et quand j'ai
le diagnostic s'est vraiment tombé comme
un soulagement parce que j'avais enfin
un mot j'avais une preuve du fait que
j'avais pas bien alors on ne devrait pas
avoir besoin de preuves pour avoir des
aménagements et pour avoir le droit des
tiers temps pour avoir le droit des
femmes ça devrait suffire de voir qu'on
va pas bien qu'on m'a l'air d'avoir très
mal mais non fallait une preuve et je me
suis dit mais c'est pas quelque chose
que j'invente c'est quelque chose qui
réalise quelque chose qui pour l'instant
ne guérira jamais parce que on n'a pas
les avancées les avancées médicales pour
ça mais c'est réel et je peux trouver
d'autres gens qui vivent la même chose
et je peux trouver une communauté et ça
fait du bien
une fragrance hôtel mandarin diagnostic
les traitements existent pour atténuer
les symptômes mais on ne guérit jamais
du syndrome d'ehlers danlos et
en pratique dans ta façon de te déplacer
tu parles tu parlais des douleurs là
aujourd'hui tu es en béquilles déplace
pas tout le temps en béquilles tu peux
tu peux raconter un peu comment ça se
passe dans ton quotidien
je me déplace de façon différente
utilise plein date à la mobilité
ça va de juste des chaussures et je vais
sur mes deux jambes à je mets des
attelles j'utilise une béquille
j'utilise deux béquilles j'utilise un
vélo mais je peux pas marcher je peut
pédaler mais je peux pas marcher
j'utilise un fauteuil roulant c'est
immense comme ça c'est laisser le sais
quoi c'est la douleur qui définissent
dans ton mode de déplacement ou séparés
il ya plein de paramètres il ya le fait
que j'ai des douleurs et que c'est
quelque chose qui fatigue qui enlèvent
des capacités d une capacité de
concentration enfin c'est surtout je
pense qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
les douleurs chroniques
c'est pas comme une fois mal au ventre
c'est on a mal au ventre tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps et autant quand on a un petit mal
de tête pendant une heure c'est pénible
mais ça passe quand on a mal à la tête
pendant deux jours d'affilée déjà ça
commence à peser donc ça prend une toute
autre dimension
donc j'essaye d'éviter ça ça peut être
pour diminuer les douleurs ça peut être
aussi pour et parmi mes articulations
pour pas me blesser parce que si je me
blesse ça veut dire encore plus de temps
de récupération encore plus de douleur
encore plus de limitations dans mes
mouvements
ça peut être aussi parce que j'ai des
choses de prévues et qu'il faut pas que
je déclenche une crise parce que je peux
forcer jusqu'à un certain point mais ça
veut dire qu'ensuite je faire une
journée dans mon lit à pleurer avoir mal
et maudire tous les gens qui m'entourent
ce qui n'est pas idéal donc parfois
j'utilise le fauteuil je peux marcher
mais j'utilise le fauteuil parce que je
sais que ça va permettre de faire plus
ça permet de faire ce que je veux et ça
va me permettre toujours de travailler
je vais passer en deux jours ou gérer
mal mais ça va pas être une semaine ça
fait deux semaines sa patte six mois
donc c'est en fonction des douleurs que
j'ai de la fragilité de mon corps et
aussi de ce que je peux me permettre de
prendre comme jours de douleurs très
étrange dit comme ça mais c'est piémont
faut que je voie par rapport à mon
planning
en fait c'est toute une organisation est
tout à l'heure tu parlais des gens qui
te disais potentiellement oui pourquoi
tu fais semblant machine à thé tard
est-ce que ça c'est quelque chose que
que les gens comprennent ou qu'il faut
que tu expliques le fait que parfois tu
as rien parfois tmb qui parfois terre en
fauteuil j'imagine que ça doit
interloqués les gens parfois oui
énormément et j'ai déjà eu même en étant
dans mon fauteuil roulant et sans m'être
levé devant la personne j'ai déjà eu un
vide qui m'a attrapée en demandant de me
justifier sur le fait que j'utilise un
fauteuil parce que ça se voyait pas que
j'étais handicapé alors que j'étais dans
mon fauteuil roulant quand même et
surtout que c'était en ville je sortais
d'un centre commercial pour rentrer dans
le erreur c'était le vigile de centre
commercial qui est censé regarder que
les gens qui rentrent et c'est plein de
petites choses comme ça qui vont arriver
au quotidien en fait et c'est épuisant
de toujours expliquer de toujours dire
ben voilà il faut il faut que tu me
fasses confiance en fait parce que c'est
ça c'est il faut que tu me fasses
confiance parce que je peux pas te
prouver que j'ai absolument besoin
d'utiliser ces appelés à ce moment là il
faut que tu me fasses confiance c'est
moi qui me connaît et faut que tu
comprennes faut que tu acceptes et ça va
pousser aussi à faire un tri dans mon
entourage
en dix ans il ya certaines personnes qui
comprennent pas qu'ils comprendront
peut-être avec le temps mais j'ai pas
cette énergie là déjà mon énergie est
limité
je n'ai pas cette énergie là à dépenser
pour expliquer pour expliquer et le fait
de faire des vidéos c'est mettre
beaucoup parce que c'est un c'est un
support que je peux envoyer aux gens
sans avoir directement à passer mon
énergie
dans l'interaction en fait et j'en
parlais avec ma marraine un repas de
famille en face aux croisés et on
parlait plein de choses et un moment on
s'est dit mais en fait mes vidéos c'est
trop bien dans notre relation parce que
comme ça ça te permet de savoir les
difficultés que je peux avoir
tu t'adaptes tu connais tous et on passe
pas les 10 fr les dix ans on passe pas
les cinq heures du repas de famille à
paris mohamed et on parle aussi de façon
nos vies de nos projets de tout ça et ça
va faire un très bon support
d'explication en fait pour que les gens
puissent voir tout ça de leur côté et
que je sois pas tout le temps dans cette
cette explication et c'est parce qu
après faut des gens ramènent leur
expérience et leur disent oui mais tu
sais j'ai connu une personne qui faisait
semblant donc c'est pour ça que je me
pose des questions est ce pas c'est
épuisant j'ai déjà une maladie qui
fatigués qui fait mal ça me rajoute et
voilà là tu parlais de tu parles de tes
vidéos et de ce que ça ce que tu as ta
porte
dans ton parcours est ce que tu sais ce
qui t'a vraiment aidé à vivre et un
syndrome directes principalement c'est
en parler parce que c'est une chose de
réfléchir dit penser dit penser seul
mais s'il ya au bout d'un moment on n'a
pas d'élément nouveau
on va voir que des points négatifs que
ce qui va pas le fait que l'on va jamais
guérir le fait qu'on a extrêmement mal
le fait que personne ne comprend tout ça
et le dire à voix haute s'est aussi déjà
trouver les mots qui vont toucher les
gens en face donc mine de rien c'est le
reformuler parce qu'il faut que les gens
puissent nous comprendre c'est aussi
échanger avec d'autres personnes voire
d'autres côté voir les améliorations que
certaines personnes ont pu amener à
toute heure leur quotidien voir
des astuces tout bête qu'on s'échange
des choses pour diminuer les douleurs
des répliques qu'on a pour casser les
proches qui vraiment bout d'un moment il
y en a marre et on trouve des réplique
du tac au tac pour juste les cas c'est
avoir un feeling de répit et c'est ça
fait énormément bien le fait d'avoir une
communauté en ligne et je ne parle pas
communauté au sens de suivi des as de la
communauté mais vraiment au sens de on a
des maladies chroniques ou alors on a
des symptômes qui sont qui se
ressemblent et on va pouvoir échanger
nos expériences et on va pouvoir parfois
juste râler en dix ans la saison là y'en
a marre j'en ai fini bonne journée
c'était épuisant dans les transports en
commun personne m'a laissé place à 6 me
suis blessé et là je vais commencer une
crise due j'en ai marre d'avoir des
communautés comme ça où on peut parler à
des gens qui nous comprennent et se
lâche et ç'a fait le premier groupe bien
aujourd'hui dans ton quotidien même si
top développé tout un tas de stratégies
d'adaptation c'est quoi le le plus
pénible pour toi premièrement je dirai
juste à mon niveau et dort ce qui me
concerne juste mois sans compter les
personnes autour je pense que c'est la
douleur parce que autant j'ai toujours
mal mais il ya des moments où c'est pire
que d'autres et où je vais pas réussir à
me concentrer où je vais pleurer ou je
vais juste parce que j'ai mal et je peux
rien faire d'autre
et je sais que je peux rien y faire et
qu'il faut juste attendre et parfois
j'ai des moments où j'ai des crises de
douleurs tels que je peux presque plus
respirer et ça dure sur quelques heures
souvent je sais que ça va passer mais
quand tu es dedans
à certains moments j'ai dit mais on
vient juste envie de mourir et c'est ça
paraît énorme à dire comme ça c'est pas
une exagération ça m'arrive
peut-être tous les trois quatre mois
j'ai ses grosses fesses de douleur et
c'est agréable du tout et quand on en
sort il ya ce côté offert au fait ça
l'est j'ai survécu
et comme ça revient on sent la douleur
arrivé lundi à annoncer bon c'est fini
c'est fini ma vie est terminée et ma
deuxième réponse et les personnes autour
qui ne comprennent pas parce que ça
punaises
argy compass a expliqué l'énergie qu'on
passe à se dire je vais pas aller à
l'affrontement même si c'est une
personne qui comprend pas même si c'est
la personne en face 14 c'est épuisant le
fait que autour se soient pas adaptées
que quand je veux sortir avec mon
fauteuil roulant je vais aller acheter
une pizza ya une marche je veux
commander une boisson dans un café le
comptoir est beaucoup trop je vois pas
le jeu voit pas les le menu le fait que
je vais aller faire mes courses au
supermarché l'ascenseur pour descendre
au rayon au rayon des fruits et des
légumes est cassée tu ne mangeras pas ce
soir c'est en permanence et en
permanence et derrière les valides qui
arrivent en disant où mais il faut
arrêter de parler tout le temps de tout
handicap parce que tu n'es pas que ça je
suis pas que ça mais dans mon quotidien
c'est ce qui me définit sais ce que je
dois prendre en compte pour sortir c'est
ce que je dois prendre en compte pour
exister donc un moment faut être
cohérent vous rendez l'espace accessible
il faut le faire est-ce que tu as
souvenir d'un conseil que quelqu'un
aurait donné et qui t'a vraiment aidé à
passer un cap ou à accepter c'est
lorsque tu vivais parfois il faut couper
il faut prendre soin de toi je pense que
c'est aussi particulier parce que je
suis dans une démarche de
sensibilisation de jeu fait des vidéos
je fais des interventions en fac je
travaille beaucoup par rapport à ça et
parfois je veux je force trop ça me
déclenché de crise je suis moins
efficace mais des
des personnes qui est juste mon arrêté
en dix ans margot maintenant tu te poses
tu arrêtes tes mails on va regarder un
film
on va regarder un truc tu lis un livre
tu te calmes et arrête parce que tu peux
pas tout rendre parfait d'un coup tu
pourras peut-être jamais de tout rendre
parfait mais faut arrêter d'essayer
parce que tu vas te casser et souvent
l'argument qui me qui me veulent plus
c'est tu arrêtes sinon tu serais moins
utile après alors que on devrait juste
pouvoir dire tu prends soin de toi parce
que c'est important mais ça fonctionne
pas toujours
mais je pense oui c'est ça juste de se
poser parfois de se faire un espace où
on sait qu'on va pas avoir un valide qui
va arriver en disant oui mais regarde
pas c'est accessible arrête deux temples
que un espace agréable et protecteur où
on peut se ressourcer et c'est super
important ne pas l'oublier
si notre quotidien est déjà assez
compliquée avec tout ça est ce qu'il ya
un message qui tient particulièrement à
coeur et que tu vas faire passer mes
styles et aux personnes qui sont pas
malades
aiguisant valide quand quelqu'un te dit
qu'ils allaient à mano qui va mal
premier réflexe tu le crois et tu fais
en sorte d'améliorer son quotidien et tu
pars pas du principe que c'est pas vrai
que la personne peut faire des efforts
que c'est extrêmement lourd à vivre si
tu peux être le soutien d'une personne
qui va mal si tu peux être le soutien
d'une personne qui a des difficultés au
quotidien
alors soit son soutien elle ce sera très
certainement une des seules personnes
sur lesquelles il peut vraiment compter
et c'est super important qu'on ait ce
soutien là et pour les personnes qui
n'ont pas bien ils sont malades qui sont
handicapés et c'est la raison d'être en
colère et a le droit d'être en colère
parce que c'est complètement injuste que
le monde soit inaccessible et parfois
juste c'est nul et c'est bien de prendre
des moments juste pour être énervé et
relâché tout la cool et toute la colère
franchement ça fait énormément de bien
je parle d'expérience et merci beaucoup
voir l'eau c'est un fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]